John Legend and his gorgeous wife
Chrissy Teigen are expecting their first
child but apparently Chrissy's cravings
have not changed much since she got
pregnant it's not that different I think
she liked sweets a little more than she
used to but other than that you know you
know she likes to eat and you know we
have a little baby that you forward to
I've seen you've been helping her out in
the kitchen a little bit a little bit I
always have you know occasionally she's
the head chef but I'm her sous-chef
sometimes and i'm in charge of breakfast
usually as well he caught up with the
crooner for the shining a light concert
wednesday to bring awareness to race
issues in America values John says he
hopes to instill in his own child I
think if you start your kids with that
love and kindness and and being
inquisitive and caring about you know
reading about it and visiting other
places and I think all that helps them
develop empathy and hopefully if all
kids have empathy then we're in good
shape